salamualikum' version on the loader i'm
the ornament or y'all look it off just
go home man love y'all wanna come on in
oh why would you buy and I would obby to
change my life forever
so I want to put this out there I've
learned a lot about stereotypes learned
a lot about because me as an
african-american I've dealt with my
share of racism people deciding not to
do this have me in mind for this or that
not only am i a black mission but I'm a
dark skinned black man some folks may
say that's old school
but it's so real I want you to
understand that I personally went and
visited the Middle East Dubai and Abu
Dhabi and I felt the love and energy in
America but out there I've never
experienced the level of love that I've
experienced in a short period of time
ever in my life and for those people of
America who because of all the terrorist
attacks and all of the things that have
happened that's associated to the Middle
East I don't want y'all to clump the
entire Middle East and all of the people
of the Middle East with the bad habits
in the bad moments that a few particular
people have done if they've done that to
black people they've done that to white
people they've done it to Latinos
because of one or several people from
one particular race or group has done it
crumped everybody all in together my
personal experience is that after my
friend Paul Walker died I was sad it's
probably my first time ever experiencing
being depressed but I didn't even know
the great nation of Abu Dhabi and Dubai
gave me my smile back and I love your
family I came home with a sense of
purpose I came home and I found my smile
again
and I just wanted to send y'all some
love and say thank you for everything
you have changed my life forever thank
you for taking care of my friends and
Will Smith
Maxwell Red Cafe just everybody that was
out there and Dubai that I personally
know thank you for everything and I will
never take my access for granted we got
big plans big ideas big big big plans so
thank you for everybody I love y'all
sending love from my backyard god bless
you should man Tyrese I'll be back soon
baby I'll be back soon peace Tyrese
Gibson and talking about the meaning of
life have you heard of this Tyrese
Gibson yes Tyrese Gibson is also like a
very good friend with Paul Walker and he
tweeted actually his video saying that
this gave me life that's amazing isn't
it I've seen the video we're going to go
to a clip of it right now so people who
haven't seen it we'll just go ahead for
30 seconds you can see it right here
then just turn up the radio as you learn
to live a lifestyle of drugs sex and
rock and roll
but in all honesty I just need to know
is there more to the cycle than growing
and getting old living and dying just to
leave behind a happy home and a whole
lot of property that somebody else is
going to own I just really need to know
before the caskets closed because I'm
not willing to gamble with my soul nor
am I ready to take any chances these are
just simple life questions and I'm just
searching for some answers like what are
we doing here and what is our purpose
how did we get here and who made us so
perfect and what happens once we go or
is this world or really worth it so in
this clip the brother goes into what
most people are doing with their life
they're just like robots just waking up
for another day another dollar like
zombies being entertained music movies
following their desires were you kind of
live in the same life yeah I mean it was
just one gig after another you know and
yeah the saying is you're only as good
as your last gig you know he he only as
good as your last job because you're
constantly chasing you chasing the the
world be chasing the dunya the material
life and you're never going to get the
you know we see this with many of the
stars or the the famous people in the
world they have everything they have the
money they have the wealth they have the
fame but they still not happy well I
mean that's that's a fact that's not
fiction and people think like okay if I
achieve this stardom I'm going to be
like just in a world of bliss but
there's some of the most miserable
people you know unhappy why you taking
drugs if you are happy yeah so when I
opened up the show and I mentioned
people such as Paul Walker the famous
movie star fast and furious and then
Tyrese Gibson who actually tweeted that
this gave this this video this meaning
of life it gave me life because it you
know when you look into Islam Islam is
not something did you find obviously the
same thing because it's not blind belief
you didn't come at this just blindly you
have to make some really big sacrifices
being a former Christian and now you are
investigating you were using
the faculties of the crater gave you the
issue to realize that to come to the
reason the realization that this is
really indeed from the Creator any other
tells us in the chronic we're not
allowed to just follow blindly you know
he tells us bring your proof if your
truth bring your proof yeah and then
this is not just for non-believers this
is also for Muslims
you know many Muslims they follow they
say the Muslim because their parents are
Muslim no this is not acceptable we need
to know why we're Muslim you know and
and other encourages to do it encourages
us to do this in the Quran by looking
for the proof you cannot by piece are we
saying this is what I've said in the
past you cannot buy a six-pack of peace
peace is something that comes from who
the Creator the Creator the maker the
one who made you so how what advice
would you give for him and and other
people now like Therese who actually the
one who tweeted this meaning of life
who's obviously that God I'm thinking so
but there's a lot of negative
stereotypes associated with Islam so
there's confusion what do you what do
you advise people look towards Islam and
that's the only option that's it that is
the only option where you gonna go I
mean where you're going to keep you know
going and following your desires and
there's no happiness there I mean the
thing is they come to the reality they
have all the money the wealth the fame
and they can't leave the house yeah you
know all the friends around them they
can't trust anyone you know it's not a
nice place to be
but with Islam so Paula you go to Mecca
for Hajj and you all wearing the same
clothes
you know the same two sheets and you
performing the rich the rituals of Hajj
and you don't know one person could be
millionaire one person can have no money
yeah you know and it's a beautiful thing
and a good a good thing to actually read
is the biography of Malcolm X and he
speaks about this when he actually went
to Hajj and he was sitting with
millionaires and poor people
they all wearing the same thing eaten
from the same pot white blood
subhanAllah beautiful so purpose of life
that's the crucial question and do you
believe that I mean that if you just
take that simple step that you ask your
maker to guide you that he'll guide you
yes III advise this a lot for people
researching put your head on the floor
in the in the in the state of
prostration like all the prophets did
and asked the creator of the universe to
show you the way to guide you to the
straight path and someone who sincerely
ask for guidance so Paulo will find it
in Islam that's it like you did you know
and so many I mean people as the fastest
growing way of life in the world today
yesterday and tomorrow it's it's growing
because it has a believable message and
it's based on proof and evidence not
blind faith is that right of course yeah
so cool to Allah who say he I lost one
God is one the maker America exactly
Allah who's somewhat lost
self-sufficient
he doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on the seventh day okay I
really had a problem with that even
before I knew anything about Islam God
resting sounds like a weak guy yeah
Lamia lid when I'm you let he begets not
he doesn't have any children never see a
child or born of anything or anyone
well I'm yeah cool I hope before I had
and there's nothing co-equal or
comparable to him at all nobody nothing
Jesus nobody nobody is comparable to the
Creator nothing yeah
and that right there was in his essence
what I believe naturally
you